hi guys this is Benny Liu from new media
rockstars calm I'm here today with
Shannon Lee actress martial artists the
CEO of Bruce Lee Enterprises and the
president of the Bruce Lee foundation
Shannon thanks a lot for joining us
today thank you thank you for having me
yeah how are you doing doing great
thanks just starting my day here and LA
doing my Bruce lady thing right on so
basically I wanted to start off this
interview with a basic but really
important question how is a Bruce Lee
relevant today meaning like how is he
relevant in today's digital generation
where you know content is widely
consumed online yeah you know he I think
my father is super relevant today for a
lot of different reasons and our hope is
to actually make him even more relevant
as we can you know because I also have
another company called Lee way media
which is a production entity and we're
looking to do more you know Bruce Lee
related content online and also you know
through traditional media we've been
working together with yo-yo Mac I don't
know if you're here with them of course
to develop some some stuff to do
together online and things like that but
I would say just generally from a you
know from a philosophical standpoint my
father is super relevant because you
know a lot of what he was doing in his
time it is really starting to be part of
the you know everyday culture and the
global community today and where you see
things like growth in you know MMA and
the UFC and all that kind of stuff and
where you see you know the world
becoming a smaller place and cultures
you know coming together and all that
sort of stuff all the things that he was
really about and about self motive
motivation and self-actualization and
all those philosophical tenets of his I
mean they're all relevant today but I
think and you know there was there's no
one else like him I don't know that I
don't think or believe that there ever
will be anyone like him
and he continues to inspire people and
that's why he's relevant right right and
why do you think the legacy left by your
father has endured for us so long I
think it's because I think to me I think
it's really because his main goal in
life was to cultivate himself and his
thoughts and ideas and his own personal
self-expression to the point where there
is no one else like him you know he
basically cultivated the one unique
product that we all have which is our
ourselves and so because of that you
know he's still around today and still
not able to be duplicated right I would
agree with you on that one
so you know let's talk about our social
media
you've done a great job in building and
managing you know the Facebook fan page
you know it currently has 2.9 million
fans so congratulations on that and you
know I'm actually you know looking
through all the posts that you made you
know you're updating it daily and the
fans are really um you know engaging um
you know what are your thoughts on this
whole social media movement and when did
you realize that this this would be an
avenue to spread your father's legacy
you know it's been a learning and a
growing process for us just like I
imagine this for everybody whenever
there's a new Avenue a new form of media
a new form of communication that comes
about you know everybody starts to dip
their toe in and then wait in a little
further and a little further you know I
think it's been about a year and a half
now that we've been slowly growing our
social media or Facebook or Twitter and
that sort of thing and you know I think
that it became a really nice method of
communication
a really nice way to like really talk to
the people who are the fans of Bruce Lee
and who are inspired by an NMR who for
one reason or another
- like a page and to get to understand
who those people are or what they want
communicate with them regularly
sometimes we do stuff that they don't
like and we take that as an opportunity
to learn from it and grow from it and I
think that the fact that our fan base is
so engaged and and part of the
conversation with us is something we
really love and something that we really
try hard to continue to grow right um
one of the things on that that we see
kind of like a trend is that um when we
interview people that were are very
experienced in the traditional media
around a lot of them are say that they
were reluctant to start using social
media at first um is that the case for
you I don't know if we were really
reluctant I think we just didn't know a
whole lot about it
so you know we weren't reluctant we
really wanted to I think like everybody
else we were like well social media
everybody's involved in social media and
I suppose we can - but but you know what
what is it exactly
how can it be beneficial can it be not
beneficial what do we need to do is it a
is it a dialogue you know um you know
think everybody it took us a while time
to understand it really is a dialogue
and you really need to engage you know
with with everybody it's not just I'm
gonna put out something and whether you
like it or you don't like it or whatever
I not care you know I really have to
care I think in order to be successful
at it right um in terms of like um you
know speaking of which um what I've been
some specific things that you discover
is the best way to reach out and you
know promote to your father's audience
you know do you see a pattern where
certain content you post does better
than the others and that drives more
engagement yeah definitely and I would
say you know we try to post fairly
frequently a photograph with maybe a
quote on it that people are really
inspired by number one his image and
number two his words and that that's an
easy thing that people can share you
know and and get a little you know
it's jolt of inspiration from as well or
just go like oh that's cool or whatever
it is you know and share that around so
we definitely see that we definitely you
know we really see it as our mission is
to continue the legacy in and by that we
mean to continue to inspire people in
the way that they are inspired when they
watch a Bruce Lee movie you get out and
then the way they're inspired when they
discover that he had a whole philosophy
and and all of that kind of stuff the
way that they're inspired when they find
out what he went through in his life so
you know that's kind of a tall order we
try to do it a little you know fun by
sideways people like the photos they
like the quotes they like it when they
get really personal content they really
like it when they you know something
with I found is like when we posted like
it for my mom for my dad to my mom you
know where we've posted something that
he wrote in his day timers or when we
posted a different poem of his I think
they really like that human connection
to feel like Bruce Lee is a human and
not just you know a Sufi and I'm like he
appears to be right right right
well actually that that um I was gonna
ask that towards the end but I guess
I'll ask you now is this kind of a good
meeting but you know a lot of people you
know blindly idolize your father and you
know put him on a pedestal and a lot has
been said about your father strengths
and talents and but from your
recollection what your family has told
you you know what what what were his
weaknesses you know he was he had
weaknesses like everybody else I'm a
very what's the word I'm looking for
from a very utilitarian point of view he
was not good at fixing things around the
house you know he was not handy with
with with his tools and things like he
had a temper you know he could get
really rough
and flat sandal and and yell and like
the good part being though that he could
also be very introspective so he could
calm down and he was you know it all
depends like my whole thing is I always
say like our strengths are also our
weaknesses and vice versa you know what
I mean so in a way it served like some
people might have said he was way too
driven he was way too this it was way to
that yeah well that's what got him to be
where he was at the same time so I'm
sure on a personal level
there were a lot of struggles in that
regard because he was you know obviously
very very focused and very very driven
but he was a great parent he really
loved us kids and all that and at the
same time you know he was practiced
sometimes leave in order to make money
to support the family and you know I
think it's the same human struggles that
everybody has to be honest you know you
know just keep his his own issues his
own things in check just like we all do
unfortunately there's a hustler so um
you know how do you see yourself and
your role in keeping up with what your
father left behind you know do you ever
feel like you know you're you're purely
under a shadow or any yeah just anything
like that yeah uh you know um yes I know
I mean if I'm being totally honest there
are times when I think well there are a
lot of things that I you know want to
work on I want to be able to do or want
people to see me for me and not see me
for Bruce Lee's daughter or what have
you but at the same time you know that's
not a huge crazy struggle in my life in
the sense that I'm like everyday like oh
it's so difficult it's just every now
and again you know it's like it's like I
love coming to work every day and I love
doing all
and what is part of what makes me love
it is that the legacy to me is so
worthwhile it's so full of so many so
much worth you know there's so much
depth of meaning so much inspiration for
not only the world but for me personally
you know so I get to come here and you
know absorb the energy of all this and
try to share it out with the world which
is something that I personally do love
for myself and if occasionally some
people can't a little bit blinded i you
know by my dad's name that's really
their issue it's not really mine you
know and and I will say I mean there was
one instance when I was making when I
was acting in my 20s and I was making a
movie in Hong Kong and that it was a big
action movie it was my first like really
big action movie and the director was
saying you know okay do it again do it
again to again and then finally said to
me just do it like your dad would do it
personally you know I would be lying if
I said oh no there's never any struggle
it's always just fine and perfect but
I'd say that the benefits hugely
outweigh any of any of those types of
things and I feel very blessed right
that's awesome
great great um you know in you know
right now certain videos from this
generation have characters that are
clear knockoffs of you know your father
like Fei Long for a street fighter and
law from Tekken I mean what do you think
of these characters that your father
inspired you know I mean what do they
say imitation is a for flattery right
yeah I think that you know I can I can
look at it from both sides right on the
one hand I would love for there to be
and something that we
actively wanting to work on is for there
to be a Bruce Lee a real official
awesome Bruce Lee video game right at
the same time the fact that everybody
associates him with the pinnacle of
martial arts with the pinnacle of action
and cool and everybody wants to emulate
him in their games and pay homage to him
it's fabulous it's beautiful right I
love it yeah so moving on to movies you
know there have been two movies I'm
depicting your father's life in detail
today you know one was made in the US
and the other was made in Hong Kong and
which in which the in the Hong Kong one
and note in the beginning that this was
purely Bruce Lee's side of the story a
Bruce Lee's family side of the story and
you know what are your thoughts on the
Hong Kong film and do you keep in
contact with their father's side of the
family
um I am in contact with my father's
family though I don't see them often and
it's rather loose contact and it ABB's
and flows sometimes at points in my life
I've seen them more than others
I have to say and this is just really
really bad on my part but I haven't
actually seen that movie oh that's no
problem but I've heard a lot about it
and I and I obviously am going to watch
it but so I don't really know the
content of that of that film that you
know intimately the direct the film
dragon you know I can't speak to any of
the pluses or minuses in the film that
my father's sibling said but I in terms
of Dragon I mean I think there were
pluses and minuses to that film as well
you know I think the spirit of that film
was really nice I think that they did to
a certain extent capture a lot of the
energy of my father and his legacy
actually it was a bit of a train wreck
and and not whole you know that whole
device that they used with the spirits
that he was battling I understand it was
it
supposed to be you know a device to sort
of speak to what perhaps his own inner
demons were but to me it was very hot I
has not done done a little bit more
flashy and unnecessary if you ask me but
but overall I think that film is a good
film from the standpoint that it it told
my father's story the essence of his
energy the essence of his struggle was
there I would I would love to see
another film about his life that really
that really got it right what is your
opinion of the of my family my father's
family's film review seen her yeah I saw
it I thought it was pretty interesting I
mean you know personally for me I
enjoyed it you know I actually liked it
more than the the u.s. one I mean I
really I feel that you know for me it
the Hong Kong one kind of captured the
essence of you know your father a little
bit better but you know that's my
personal opinion but you should
definitely watch it though I you know as
a viewer I did enjoy it yeah good now I
definitely want to watch it yeah
and I also saw the documentary I at the
I am Bruce Lee documentary that was
really really good I mean I that's the
best documentary I've seen of him like
to date so you know yeah we really love
that and actually that documentary is
now just the the u.s. DVD release has
just launched and we're selling it at
Bruce Lee calm but I thought that was a
really wonderful documentary I was
really really pleased with how it came
out
I thought the director Pete McCormack
did an amazing job and that today it is
the best documentary yeah definitely
definitely well you know speaking of
like you know movies and video content
um you mentioned that oh I see that you
have a youtube channel already and you
know you're uploading it seems like
you're uploading one video per month
that includes like clips of your dad you
know and your brother and also some
personal vlogs
you mention that you're working with
young MF which is you know definitely
one of the biggest YouTube networks
right now and I'm you know explain tell
me of more about your plans for YouTube
and what you plan on doing with me on
that yeah well we're we're hatching our
plans with the Army on map we're working
on creating a series for you know maybe
starting with like six small webisodes
or something and then drawing it from
there if it goes well but right now the
stuff we're talking about is a little
more comedic in nature you know those
still surrounding the legacy obviously
but we're we haven't fully drilled down
on exactly what the what the show idea
is gonna be but we're having a lot of
fun trying to figure it out and in terms
of YouTube you know we would we do have
our own channel and we would like to to
grow that more and put more of our own
content up there we are right now
working on a mini documentary for the
bonus materials of the 40th anniversary
blu-ray of Enter the Dragon that will
come out this in the summer so you know
we're stuck we're really starting to
ramp up our production side of things we
want to get new new content out there
hold on that's more than documentary
content you know we'd really like to
create some creative projects right
right and for your YouTube channel in
particular I mean I don't know if you
know that all these YouTube networks are
you know kind of growing and signing on
you know different talents and stuff
like that do you guys do you have any
plans or any any a desire to maybe join
like a YouTube network we don't have any
plans at the moment as to desire I think
there's potentially some desire there I
would depend on you know exactly exactly
what we would do right that makes
perfect sense yeah yeah I mean we're
always looking for new new and
interesting ways to grow and to reach
more people so we would definitely be
interested in exploring that
okay great and then my second to last
question um you know regarding to your
rerunning your father and your brother
you know this there's oh there's been a
lot of speculation today you know that
your father's and brothers desk we're
awesome how part of this big conspiracy
and you know people have dubbed it like
the Bruce Lee curse you know what are
your personal thoughts on all that all
that stuff you know I mean I think that
I understand it from a cultural
standpoint I guess but I obviously don't
think that there's curse if I did I
would probably be afraid to leave my
palace every day but you know I think
that there were they were two very
tragic and circumstances that were very
different and in it and it was very
unfortunate that they happened to happen
you know for the most part almost
exactly 20 years apart and that it's
easy to grab any similarities and look
at something like that I'm sure there
have been many families that have had
more than one tragedy within them and
people don't go around calling that a
curse and that's because they're not
famous and in front of the public eye
you know what I mean so to me it's like
oh it was a it was a very unfortunate
thing that happened has happened in my
family but you know it gives me the
impetus to just keep on going and living
my life to the fullest so great um and
my last question is you kind of
mentioned is above all ready but I do
you have any other of big projects they
like to reveal to us at this time and
where would be the best place for our
readers to go to to kind of see what the
what the latest happenings are you know
adversity legacy okay yeah well I
mentioned that the us DVD release of
iron Bruce Lazar is out and available
people can obviously go to Bruce Lee
comm we've got a fun store and a lot of
you know videos that we post on YouTube
and that you can connect to through our
site and all that
we're having a big fundraiser on
February 9th in Seattle Washington for
the Bruce Lee action museum which is a
project that the Bruce Lee foundation is
undertaking to build a facility
dedicated to my father's legacy and in
particular to his legacy of action we
really want we really want it to be a
living Institute more than a you know
just a memorabilia museum we really want
to focus on the different types of
action that he undertook or came across
in his life whether it's Marshall or
filmic or philosophical a cultural and
to explore that for his legacy as well
as being able to explore it through
other people's legacies as well and we
really want it to be a this amazing
project so we're having a fundraiser
February 9 in Seattle for anyone who
last-minute wants to take a trip to
Seattle but we're looking to put in
Seattle because you know my my father
and my brother are buried in Seattle and
it's already a place that a lot of
people go to to visit the gravesite
it's where he had his first school it's
where he met my mom he went to the
University of Washington so that's awful
a lot of reasons that Seattle seems like
a good fit you can go to Bruce Lee
foundation org to look at the works of
the foundation and to read about the
event pretty soon we're gonna have a
Bruce Lee action museum website up
probably in the next few weeks we have
at Bruce Lee legacy on Twitter and we
have our Bruce Lee Facebook page we are
also putting a working of just launching
a project next week to put a community
piece garden on the campus at the
University of Washington dedicated to my
father it's great so I mean you know
there's just a lot going on like I said
the the bonus materials for the 40th
anniversary and the Dragon and there's
just a lot happening all the time
good keep it busy that's always nice
yeah it's great so people you know
follow us a little bit through our
various avenues they'll definitely be
kept apprised of all the happenings
hello and oh I have to ask you this um
do you if you have any cool like a Bruce
Lee relics that you think you have kind
of at the house or anything that you can
show us or you know we have I'm at my
office right now and we have the archive
here
I should mention actually we're opening
on in July I'm not sure if I have the
date yet
a three year exhibit with the Hong Kong
Heritage Museum
so actually setting over more than 500
items of my father's personal effects to
be displayed at the Hong Kong Heritage
Museum in the summer of this year also
so we have some stuff oh no should I run
and grab something to show you really
fast so uh what kind of rolls would you
like to show us so this is the headstone
I don't know if you know what this is
but my father had this made it's really
heavy it's like made out of iron and it
says on it in memory of a once fluid man
crammed and distorted by the classical
mess and he asked his friend George Lee
to make this for him and that and that
came out of in 1965 he had a challenge
match with the Chinese martial arts
community in the Bay Area they
challenged him because he was teaching
martial arts to non Chinese and they
were all up in arms about it so they
challenged him to imagine if he won and
he had to stop if he won that he could
keep going and if they won then he had
to stop and he he entered this match
with their champion that they brought
over and he won in three minutes but at
the end of it instead of being super
happy he was kind of upset and and he
was upset because it was upset with his
performance he really felt like
his physical fitness level wasn't as
high as it should be in that his
training in traditional martial arts in
Wing Chun had not really prepared him
for to encounter this type of a
no-holds-barred battle and so that was
really the impetus of him starting to
break away and wanting to and creating
ultimately his own martial art called G
kundo
and so what he did was he asked George
to create this for him in as sort of a
symbol of his death as you will to the
traditional martial arts and then his
rebirth back into fluidity that's
amazing so yeah so he had this created
and then do you want to see the glasses
again yes please yeah these are a pair
of his eyeglasses that he wore this may
look look like something Bruce Lee would
have worn and you can tell but one of
the reasons I love them is because you
can see how absolutely nearsighted he
was I mean if you look at the distortion
in the lenses and then also from the
side you can see how thick they are they
stick out past the frames which these
frames are pretty thick so so he was
very nearsighted my father he almost
always had glasses or contacts on so you
know and just like that human element
today so yeah because to us he's like a
superhero that's right he was a very
nearsighted superhero all right well you
know thanks a lot for joining us you
know I appreciate you know you taking
time and everything oh thank you thank
you for contacting us I'm happy you
noted our progress and that were and
then we're getting out there and I
appreciate the time as well you guys are
doing a great job it's amazing thank you
thank you so much all right take care
so chair right